marc êtes vous d'accord avec le fait
qu'on ne doit pas dire aux petits
garçons que pleurer c'est pour les
filles
si vous êtes d'accord j'aimerais bien
que vous leviez la main s'il vous plaît
êtes vous d'accord avec le fait qu'à
compétences et poste similaire
les femmes devraient gagner autant que
les hommes lever la main s'il vous plaît
si vous êtes d'accord
merci
êtes vous d'accord avec moi si j'affirme
que les femmes devraient pouvoir évoluer
dans l'espace public en toute sérénité
sans avoir peur de se faire siffler ou
de se faire agresser sexuellement lever
la main s'il vous plaît merci et bien
c'est formidable vous êtes tous et
toutes féministes nous sommes toutes et
tous féministe merci bon break j'ai un
petit peu de temps encore et puisque le
sujet quand même un peu moins léger un
peu moins futiles que ça autant autant
en profiter
je vais vous raconter ce que m'a apporté
le féminisme à titre personnel les
bonnes choses et aussi les mauvaises
pour cela j'aurais remonter quelques
années en arrière pendant la décennie
qui vient de s'écouler j'ai été victime
de cyber harcèlement alors le cyber
harcèlement
qu'est ce que c'est et bien c'est le
fait quand on ouvre les réseaux sociaux
qui constituent l'un des principaux
outils de travail de ne pas savoir à
quel moment on va se noyer sous les
flots de propos insultants et menaçants
humiliant diffamatoire ça ce n'est que
la partie émergée de l'iceberg
mais croyez bien qu'elle fait déjà
extrêmement mal mais effectivement ce
n'est pas tout parce que le
cyberharcèlement ça ne s'arrête pas
quand l'ordinateur c'est un ca se
propage dans ce qu'on appelle la vraie
vie je vous donne un exemple
un soir on sonne à votre porte vous êtes
tranquillement installé en famille c'est
un livreur de pizza ils vous apportent
de pizzas que vous n'avez absolument pas
commander vous lui dites vous lui dites
qu'il ya erreur vous vérifié le bon de
commande avec lui c'est effectivement
votre nom votre adresse
vous finissez par accepter les pizzas
parce que vous ne pouvez pas prouver que
vous nous avez pas commander et puis le
lendemain on sonne de nouveau à la porte
à la même heure à peu près c'est le même
livreur de pizza cette fois il a pas de
pizza
il en a 8 et vous n'avez toujours
évidemment rien commandé vous ne tardez
pas alors à comprendre qu'il se passe
quelque chose et que quelque part des
gens ont décidé qu à présent leur hobby
principale consisterait à s'arranger
pour que plus jamais vous vous entier en
sécurité
même au sein de votre foyer mène avec
votre famille alors quand on est victime
de harcèlement ou de cyber harcèlement
puisqu'au fond à part le support c'est à
peu près la même chose
toutes les victimes finissent par avoir
les mêmes réactions
elle se demande est ce qu'elles ont pu
faire pour que ça tombe sur elle ce que
je voudrais que vous reteniez
particulièrement c'est qu'aucune
personne je dis bien aucune n'est jamais
responsable du harcèlement qu'elle subit
aucune
malgré tout j'ai commis la même erreur
que toutes les autres victimes de
harcèlement j'essayais de comprendre
pourquoi j'ai essayé de comprendre
pourquoi c'était tombé sur moi et pas
sur mon voisin où ma voisine
j'ai essayé de me demander pourquoi
j'avais pu attirer l'attention sur moi
qu'est-ce qui avait fait que j'étais
donc la victime de harcèlement de de
longue date ont réalisé dans mon cas
personnel ça n'a pas été très compliqué
à comprendre
il s'avère que depuis maintenant d'assez
longues années j'exprime grâce aux
médias qu'ils m'en laisse la possibilité
ou sur les réseaux sociaux
j'exprime mes conditions mes convictions
profondément proféministes alors
voilà on a des idées de deux ruine et ma
vie de pourrir mon quotidien et celui de
mes proches
simplement parce que j'ai osé exprimer
des convictions féministes l'euphémisme
au fond c'est quoi
comment on peut le définir simplement
est bien une des définitions qu'on peut
donner c'est le fait que toutes les
personnes devraient avoir les mêmes
droits et les mêmes devoirs
quel que soit le premier numéro le
premier chiffre de leur numéro de
sécurité sociale c'est aussi simple que
ça et moi grâce à l'éducation qu'ils ont
apporté à des tas de militantes
féministes et qu il continue d'ailleurs
à ma portée au quotidien j'ai essayé moi
aussi de propager cette parole et
expliqué notamment que les hommes ont
énormément de privilèges il en a encore
plus ils sont blancs s'ils sont
hétérosexuels s'ils sont classe moyenne
ou supérieure
j'expliquais également qu'il était temps
que tout ça soit redistribuer de façon
bien plus équitable mais beaucoup
d'hommes ne voit pas les choses de cette
oreille et en particulier merci de leurs
ce que je considère moi comme étant des
privilèges qu'il est normal de
redistribuer de partager pour eux il
s'agissait d' acquis fondamentaux qu'il
était hors de question de céder aux
autres au fond j'ai fini par me dire
qu'ils se comportaient comme des trente
trois ans un enfant de trois ans quand
il a trop de jouets qu'on essaye de lui
en prendre un peu pour en donner à ceux
qui en ont moins
il ya plusieurs façons de réagir il peut
tout à fait obtempéré gentiment et puis
assez fréquemment
il aura une autre réaction il va crier
il va taper il va essayer de mordre
il aura l'impression de vivre une
profonde injustice parce qu'il a trois
ans sauf que je ne voulais pas d'enfants
de trois ans je vous parle d'homme de 15
25 35 45 ans qui se comportaient comme
des gamins à la crèche
j'ai poursuivi ma réflexion et puis je
me suis dit qu'en fait mais harceleur et
moi on avait quand même on était quand
même d'accord sur un point on est
d'accord sur le fait qu'en fait les
hommes n'ont rien à gagner au féminisme
pourquoi est ce que les hommes se
battrait pour pour le féminisme est ce
que vous connaissez beaucoup d'hommes
qui sont victimes de propos déplacés ou
deux mains baladeuses de leurs
supérieurs ou leurs collègues
est ce que vous connaissez beaucoup
d'hommes à qui on a déjà reproché d'être
habillé trop sexy ou pas assez est ce
que vous connaissez beaucoup d'hommes
qui ont déjà dû presser pas dans la rue
parce que des inconnus voulait
absolument leur demander leur numéro de
portable
moi j'en connais pas sauf que pour mes
harceleur et pour d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'autres hommes qui n'ont jamais harcelé
sa a justifié le fait de ne pas se
battre
tout va bien et moi au contraire ça me
rend vraiment marteau
cette somme d'inégalités actuellement
accablante qui rendent le quotidien des
femmes mille fois plus compliqué il voit
plus accidenté que celui des hommes
alors comment ça se manifeste que le
féminisme quotidien ça peut être très
simple parce qu'on va être mais
harceleur il avait l'impression que moi
j'étais quelqu'un d' extrémistes que je
voulais remettre en question toute la
façon de penser d'agir de vivre des
hommes
or non l'euphémisme ça peut être quelque
chose de très doux au départ de très
progressif on avance pas à pas ça
commence par remettre en question son
rapport aux autres son rapport à
l'humour par exemple l'emploi d'un
certain vocabulaire se demander si on
est parent si on allait vraiment de la
même façon ses fils et ses filles se
demander pour absolument chacun et
chacune d'entre nous si on traite les
femmes avec autant de respect que les
hommes
et puis au final on se rend compte quand
même quand on a ce comportement au
quotidien que même si on n'a pas grand
chose de concret à y gagner
l'euphémisme peut quand même nous
apporter beaucoup de choses à nous les
hommes
en premier lieu nous apprend l'empathie
l'empathie c'est ce qui fait qu'on
arrive ou qu'on essaye en tout cas de se
mettre à la place des autres personnes
pour essayer de comprendre ce qu'elles
ressentent l'empathie c'est quelque
chose que l'on enseigne beaucoup aux
petites filles en leur mettant notamment
des plus jeunes âges un poupon dans les
bras et en lui nommant leur demandant de
s'en occuper
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs que encore
à l'heure actuelle il ya beaucoup plus
d'infirmières que l'infirmier beaucoup
plus d'assistantes sociales que
d'assistants sociaux parce que
l'empathie c'est quelque chose qu'on
apprend beaucoup moins aux petits
garçons et petits garçons
on leur apprend plutôt à jouer des
coudes pour essayer de gravir les
échelons et ça ça crée des déséquilibres
absolument terrible mois une féministe
[Musique]
noire américaine qui écrit des essais
s'appelle roxane gay est quelqu'un que
j'aime énormément qui a écrit un essai
que j'affectionne tout particulièrement
qui s'appelle bad féministe mauvaise
féministe dans lequel elle développe un
tas de thèse a tellement passionnante
mais il dit également cette chose très
courte mais d'apparence très simple
roxane cas elle dit le féminisme m'a
apporté la paix mais en réalité
peut-être pour des raisons complètement
différentes des siennes
mais moi aussi j'ai l'impression que
j'ai féminisme m'a apporté la paix
malgré la livraison pizza inopinés c'est
à dire que même si je ne serai jamais
satisfait de mon degré d'engagement même
si je ne serai jamais satisfait de la
façon dont ce monde évolue j'ai tout de
même un tout petit peu de moins de mal à
me regarder dans la glace le matin quand
je me lève je vais vous citer une autre
phrase celle là je suis certain que vous
la connaissez toutes et tous une phrase
de simone de beauvoir simone de beauvoir
elle a écrit qu'on ne naît pas femme on
le devient
et bien pour la singer vraiment
vulgairement j'ai envie de vous dire que
on ne naît pas féministe on devient on
observe comment la planète tourne c'est
à dire de façon totalement bancale on se
dit qu'on peut pas rester les bras
ballants et qu'on va essayer à sa
modeste échelle de contribuer à
rectifier de légèrement sa trajectoire
et donc ça peut se matérialiser par des
tas de petits gestes du quotidien
d'apparence anodine mais qui vont déjà
peut-être modifier le quotidien des
femmes qui nous entoure alors moi à
titre personnel j'ai fini par me rendre
compte que le féminisme de ces petits
gestes du quotidien
il était plus suffisant pour moi je me
sentais pas en total accord avec mes
convictions avec mes lectures et donc
petit à petit j'avais décidé d'aller
plus loin
alors j'ai deux exemples à vous donner
j'appartenais une bande d'amis dans
laquelle plus un homme se comporter de
façon dégueulasse avec les femmes plus
il était valorisé c'était plus tolérable
pour moi alors j'ai décidé purement et
simplement de rompre avec ses amis et
puis j'ai décidé de continuer à faire un
peu le ménage autour de moi en réalisant
que une partie des gens avec qui je
passais mes samedis soirs où mes
week-ends nous semble hélas c'est aussi
assez irrécupérable sur ce genre de
sujet je vous donne un deuxième exemple
je suis mariée depuis maintenant plus de
huit ans avec une femme que j'aime et
qui m'aiment aussi j'espère et bien même
si elle porte un anneau symbole de notre
union j'estime n'être en rien son
propriétaire elle ne m'appartient pas il
son corps il ses pensées ni ses désirs
et aujourd'hui depuis
que année cette femme vit parallèlement
à la nôtre une deuxième histoire d'amour
parce que je suis qui mois pour
m'imposer comme le seul phare de son
existence alors les choix peuvent vous
sembler radicaux d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez que je ne vous demande pas
d'imiter mais mes choix de vie mais en
fait ce qui est important à retenir
c'est que nous pouvons toutes et tous
chercher dans notre quotidien dans notre
façon de vivre des façons de vivre
pleinement le féminisme en cohérence
avec ce que nous voulons pour le monde
de demain
or voilà ce que je vous encourage à
faire observer autour de vous demandez
vous chaque jour ce que vous pouvez
faire d'un peu plus que la veille et
surtout remet tombe toujours en question
vivons toujours dans un état
d'insécurité intellectuelle permanente
n'ayant jamais l'impression d'être
arrivé au bout de chemin parce que ce ne
sera jamais le cas ni pour vous ni pour
moi en matière de féminisme le la
perfection n'existe pas mais le monde a
quand même sacrément besoin qu'on essaye
de s'en rapprocher
merci
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]